right so yeah when i was um 17 maybe 18
i went for a hand modeling job i thought
that's all right i'm only five foot one
they i don't this this doesn't work for
modeling but hands i can do beautiful
yeah beautiful plans i can do went into
a room full of very it was a very white
room it was a very english room walked
in i thought it'd be fine it'll be fine
i'm used to this i can go in a room and
i'm usually very different so it's
absolutely fine went in thought nothing
of it and then she she kind of didn't
even pull me up to her side and just
said
i'm so sorry but brown hands don't sell
jewelry and i was like oh
okay that's amazing that she said that
out loud out loud in an entire room of
people
yeah and and um since then
got married and i can wear that that's
great
um and um but you know since then i've
worked with swarovski loads and and and
i got to do my hand modelling so yeah
lady
yeah
i think
you sort of think of other things to do
with your hands for that lady
yeah i would have been like oh does this
look good
yeah does this go with what you want
was
to
sell
that was my instagram post that was my
favorite it was my exact instagram post
it was like this that's when i first
wrote your husband i saw it that day and
was like i i like you but i like him
better and he's fine
olaf you can't talk like this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you